Brandon after the accident against the
Balaji you're back in this tournament
with a crucial Victory how important was
for you to get a victory in today's
round
yeah no I I missed chances pretty much
every game
um against Balaji I kind of got over
ambitious with Queen B6 I had no reason
to lose that game and then against
Arthur yesterday I had a big chance with
E4 instead of Bishop C6 and then it kind
of fizzled out so it was definitely
important I keep missing all my chances
but I think the main adjustment I made
was just trying not to be upset with
myself about mistakes because I think
normally my major this tournament has
been like once I'm making an accuracy
I'm getting kind of upset with myself
I'm not able to psychologically adjust
so I think I did that a lot better this
game and kept focused the whole 100 move
game and another aspect that I noticed
is that despite the fact that you want
to win you need to win you're still not
playing this super sharp lines you want
to keep the game long was that part of
the strategy as well well yeah so in the
opening I played this bishop t7 move um
so the the best line or sorry starting
with H6 yes instead of H6 I mean the
main line it was taken Bishop G4 which I
assume he prepared but I remember it's
some I guess some pretty dry positions
so I mean it's I'm going to transpose
the kind of something that I've analyzed
it's kind of interesting because
what you did against Bellagio right
right I've analyzed some positions where
White's actually sort of down a full
Tempo because he went Bishop C so like
he went D3 D4 the bishop on C2 and then
A4 yeah like in some position in a
normal Roy where he because Bishop's on
B3 gets D4 and one move then A4 in one
move so it's like he wasted me with his
Bishop yeah but the thing is his Knight
is on F ones that are G3 which could
actually help him in some cases because
he goes through so I need to think
exactly so I try to figure out the
differences now I'm not sure if what I
did was correct but it felt like kind of
the principal way I think it was yeah
because so the point is if if Queen
takes A4 instead of Earth takes A4
um C6
and the point is now if C4 I'm in time
for Knight B7 items or 90 seconds same
thing and and he can cook me takes his
Queen gets traps and now he can't go the
point is he can't go Bishop B3 to defend
now because E4 is hanging so this Knight
to see yeah
so
yeah so C6 dc6 and now I think Queen B6
might have been a bit I'm not sure if it
was actually the correct move
um all right well computers yeah all
right I thought maybe he should try like
let's say queen C2 instead of um 93 yes
uh Queen takes C6 and Bishop E3 is a
little bit afraid of this because then
it just goes Rook A1 next and okay at
some point I can give D5 and I'm
probably okay but I don't know I'm gonna
win this game and also I mean A5 is
always is a week long term I think if
you're only gives point three but I felt
a little bit dangerous
which makes a lot of sense but I wasn't
too afraid of it because yeah I think
I'm pretty well placed for all this yeah
for Queen D2 I felt like I might have
missed a chance around here um was Queen
B3 any good maybe instead of Queen B5
no apparently not all right because I
was thinking maybe Queen B3 and if okay
if you take excited Knight F6 and you
can't defend upon his issues so Rook A1
and then F6 here but I guess you can
just play some of the queen C1 that's
not yeah and I think this was getting
Knight to D2 was critical for his
chances throughout the game like right
especially when uh he played Knight F6
91 that was the mistake that was
supposed to go Queen A2 and then I did
two and then yeah it's kind of hard to
do that because I mean I can give Bishop
B7 Bishop T and keep the pawn exactly so
yeah yeah I figured it probably has some
accurate with equalized here but I
thought at least was trying everything I
could try of course seeing how it goes
yeah so 91 I kind of felt like I might
have let it slip a bit before the time
control but I I think I did a good job
of keeping pressure the whole game even
if even if it was a draw at some point
um by the way he found this nice idea
with Rook A6 on move 30 um because the
issue because like I think it's actually
a pretty nice defense because I can't
get Rick C2 now because I mean like I
can but Queen takes C2 Queen E1 King H2
Queen takes E3 and yeah he can go Queen
C7
Queen C7 I guess I can see a lot of
draws but yeah I thought simplest
between 27. my queen is kind of shut out
okay seven yeah right you have to so
so yeah I think what I did was the most
principled
um I'm not exactly sure where he went
wrong but like my only job was just to
keep putting pressure even if it was a
drug exactly so like every I mean it was
actually kind of simple for me to play
because like I was just playing the move
that I felt like kept the initiative
going every move and like I didn't
really have much of a choice I think it
was still equal still equal I'm
surprised somewhere around here but this
is already starting to become extremely
uncomfortable right yeah exactly and the
issue is pieces are so jumbled up as
Rick can never really get active because
pieces are so loose I think this was the
question yeah I thought he should try
waiting yeah yeah I can't have one so
the point is that his night like the
night in The Rook are kind of like it's
like kind of like a mutual Zoom because
I don't want to let his Knight get to an
active Square before like if you always
have like 983 for example but 3c4
exactly so it kind of makes sense from
the way yeah Enrique I think it's I
guess he's in time for his kind of
really but that's already very difficult
yeah
um and yeah I think in the game like in
H4 yeah H4 felt felt wrong but already
it's very uncomfortable I thought he
would play like King F1 and ic2 and
disorder place but I think eventually I
will win the d-pawn and okay I'm up upon
the game goes on but I think practically
it's very difficult for white and yeah I
mean once the pawn is fixed on H4 I
think it's pretty much game over your
tournament the Juniors is very very
tight at the top a lot of players are
vying for position Arthur guo is
definitely one of the surprises I would
say of uh this event how would you uh
anticipate the last couple of rounds
play out
yeah it's tough I mean also I think like
Abby's halfway behind yeah so I think
you know it's kind of hard to say
anything right now like philano Arthur
will win the last two games there's
nothing I can do so all I can really do
is play my best chess the last three
games and see how it goes but it's
really interesting and I did not expect
like I knew it was going to be close but
I didn't expect it to be this close like
it's really anybody's game at this point
guys any questions for Brandon
yeah Brandon I have a question so two
rounds to go are you going to take risks
like play it you know risk position even
if it's a draw that you don't want to
draw because you really want to go for
the first place or are you just happy
you know if you finish second third
you're not going to be risking that much
well I don't think I should answer that
question right now but I mean I think it
sort of depends on on a lot of things
right it depends on the positions they
get into the opening the position you
know how everybody else is doing but in
terms of my strategy there's not really
much I can really do besides play my
best and see how it goes because I think
it's a bit too soon to go all out to try
to win when there's still two games left
and I think can happen
absolutely thank you well out
congratulations Brandon good luck in the
rest of the tournament to do more rounds
to go round